uh
and the reputation of canada throughout
the world
have been threatened consistently
in a coordinated manner
has been
receiving funding from abroad this
situation cannot be tolerated in our
country
cabinet invoked the emergencies act to
restore public order
information is now being shared
by law enforcement with canada's
financial institutions
financial service providers have already
taken action
based on that information
the emergency measures we put in place
are being used
they are having an impact
and they will have a growing impact in
the days to come
the measures we enacted
this
as well to communicate
information
and financing to unlife unlawful
blockades since monday's announcement
i've spoken directly with the heads of
our major banks
and with the director of fintrac
my cabinet colleagues and i are meeting
regularly
very regularly including with the
commissioner of the rcmp
to discuss next steps
our absolute priority is ending these
illegal blockades and occupation
it gives me no pleasure to impose any of
these measures
in fact we do so with great sorrow
but do not doubt our determination to
act
to defend our democracy
to defend our economy
and to restore peace
order
and good government
so let me repeat what i said on monday
if your truck
is being used in these protests
your corporate accounts
will be frozen
the insurance on your vehicle
will be suspended
the consequences are real
and
they will bite
it is time for you to go home
and let me also be clear that we will
have zero tolerance for the
establishment of new blockades or
occupations
we now have the tools
to follow the money
we can see what is happening
and what is being planned in real time
and we are absolutely determined that
this must end
now and for good
before turning to my colleagues i want
to make one additional but unrelated
announcement
one that will be welcome news for cities
across the country
the federal government will be providing
a one-time 750 million dollar top-up of
transit funding for municipalities to
help make up for some of the pandemic
related operating shortfalls that
transit systems have been experiencing
this funding is contingent on two
very reasonable requirements
first
that our provincial and territorial
partners
match the funding we the federal
government will be providing
and second that provinces work to speed
up their actions to improve housing
supply in collaboration with
municipalities
housing is a shared responsibility and
we all have an important role to play
federal the federal government will
provide two municipalities
750 million
funding transit systems
living conditions in our communities we
must ensure that our
municipalities are able
to face the economic repercussions that
are ongoing from the penalties
thank you very much
good thing they brought this step for
you bill
good morning beaumate
thank you for joining us today
i want to begin by highlighting two
important developments that happened
late yesterday
last night in the house of commons i
officially tabled a motion for
confirmation of the emergency
declaration under the emergencies act
and just a few minutes ago
i spoke to this motion during the debate
over the next few days i look forward to
a very vigorous exchange with members of
all parties at this important and unique
moment
along with the prime minister and my
minister colleagues we will be
explaining to canadians how we got to
this point why the emergencies act is
necessary and where we go from here
as always we will explain clearly and
openly how we're acting in the best
interests of canadians
as well yesterday afternoon i can
confirm that the emerson border crossing
officially reopened
emerson is manitoba's most important
link to the united states
a vital crossing point for travelers and
trade
and with this significant step
i'm pleased to share that all ports of
entry on the canada-us border are now
clear
of illegal blockades and open to traffic
but i also want to add that this process
is not set in progress is not set in
stone and nor should we assume that it
is linear
yesterday we saw a group of illegal
blockades attempt to return to the
ambassador bridge
to once again
choke this vital trade quarter off and
the impact that that would have had not
only in southwestern ontario but right
across the country cannot be overstated
and it can't be allowed to happen
and that's exactly why we invoked the
emergencies act
law enforcement must have all of the
tools that they need to ensure that
these crossings stay open
but i want to be clear that the very
targeted tools that we've introduced
under the emergencies act are time
limited and they are protected by the
safeguards which are enshrined in our
charter
this means that whether you are a law
enforcement person or any other
individual that is
assisting
under the emergencies act that you are
bound
to act in compliance with the charter
every day
some 50 million dollars in trade passes
through the couts crossing and at the
ambassador bridge it's nearly 400
million
it's no exaggeration to say that these
illegal blockades have already cost our
economy in the billions
but these aren't just numbers they're
jobs for canadians
it's about the rancher near lethbridge
who sells alberta beef to hungry
families in the united states or the
auto worker at the chrysler plant in
windsor who builds cars for markets
across north america
we owe it to them and to all canadians
to ensure that these vital corridors
remain open for business
there's no ordinary law
but we know that we are in no ordinary
time
as former minister perrin beatty said
when introducing it in 1988 the
emergencies act is quote
an ability to enable the federal
government to fulfill its constitutional
responsibility
to provide for safety and security of
canadians during national emergencies
keeping canadians safe is a
responsibility that we take very
seriously
and it is one that we will fulfill
thank you merci i'll pass it over to my
friend and colleague minister blair
thank you very much marco
and deputy prime minister always an
honor and privilege to be with you good
morning everyone um
i'd like to thank you all for joining us
here today to enable us and give us the
opportunity to provide an impact and to
answer
uh canadians important questions on this
matter as my colleagues have said
currently all of our ports of entry with
the united states are open
trade trades and goods and people
are once again moving freely
travelers and commercial vehicles are
getting where they need to go
unimpeded by illegal blockades
and i'd like to take this opportunity to
thank our law enforcement partners for
safely and successfully clearing these
vital passages in british columbia
alberta manitoba
and ontario over the past few days
and while we all breathe a sigh of
relief
as has mr mendocino shared with you we
know that these blockades could very
easily reappear
and as we saw yesterday as evidenced in
windsor the intent
to harm our economy and hurt canadians
unfortunately remains
i'd like to thank local law enforcement
for their swift action in windsor in
preventing another illegal blockade from
fracturing the critical economic
recovery
of this country
the removal of these blockades has
restored the strength of our economy
they've ensured that the safe and free
passage of goods between canada and the
united states is secure
and most importantly they have made sure
that canadians are able to get back to
work and get their lives back to normal
in ottawa we're continuing to see
progress being made by the ottawa police
service the ontario police provincial
police and the rcmp and all of their
policing partners
as they work to end the occupation of
wellington street and downtown ottawa
yesterday interim chief bell stated that
officers have been going from truck to
truck to advise individuals that they
are participating in an illegal
demonstration
and they have made it crystal clear
that if the illegal demonstrators do not
leave
they will face serious consequences
interim chief bell has also confirmed
that he is confident that the ottawa
police service and the integrated
command unit have the appropriate
resources authorities that they require
and a
very concrete plan to move forward
he emphasized that this operation will
not be considered complete
until the streets are cleared
and that peace and order has been fully
restored
to the good people of the city of ottawa
to the individuals who continue to
participate in this illegal occupation
it's time to go home
now
and to those who have children with them
this is no place for children take them
home immediately take them to a place of
safety
the ottawa police service and their
partners have engaged the planning team
with the children's aid society to
encourage anyone with children in the
area
to leave immediately and to take their
kids to some place safe
to the people of ottawa i want to assure
you
we will continue to work and support
with our municipal and provincial
partners
to make sure that this occupation ends
safely and swiftly and respectful of
charter rights and freedoms and
upholding the rule of law
so that they can get their city back and
they can get their lives back
the decision to invoke the emergency act
was one as the deputy prime minister
said that we took with great caution and
care
and i will share with you as she did
we approached it even with sincere
regret
regret that this was necessary
but make no mistake we were resolved to
do what was required
to uphold the rule of law
to protect protect canadians interests
and to defend our country our democratic
institutions
and our the people of this country we
know that it was necessary
to give law enforcement and our other
officials the tools authorities and
resources that they require to do the
job
and i want to assure all canadians we
will not hesitate to do whatever is
required to protect our ports of entry
to protect canadian interests from the
criminal intent of people behind these
blockades
and to restore
peace and order in our country
and finally to the people and residents
of ottawa i want to acknowledge how they
have suffered
from threats of threats and intimidation
from acts that were clearly intended to
greater bring the greatest disruption to
the lives
of their fellow citizens
and indeed all canadians i want to
assure them that this will end
and that we
will be there for them to continue to
support them and to hold those
who have taken from them
the peace of their of their
neighborhoods and their communities we
will hold them to account for their
actions thank you all very much merci
beaucoup um i would like to invite uh
people who may have questions of myself
and my colleagues please proceed
from journalists until 11 55 and we'll
start in the room
hi it's annie bergeron oliver with ctv
national news my question is for you
minister freeland you mentioned in your
opening remarks that action is being
taken by financial services and that's
making a difference i'm wondering if you
can provide any specific numbers on how
many accounts either personal or
corporate are being targeted
and also what type of safeguards are in
place to ensure that it's protesters and
not simply someone with the same name
whose accounts are being targeted and
frozen
uh well thank you very much for the
question
i have those numbers here in front of me
and they were reviewed just last night
by me
and minister mendicino minister blair
the prime minister and minister lametty
but i'm not going to share them
with you right now because operational
actions are being taken and we want to
be very very careful not to jeopardize
those operational actions but i do want
to assure you and through you all
canadians
that action is being taken
we are seeing it
and that action is going to increase in
the coming days
um
it's a good question about
uh
what are the safeguards and there i
really want to assure all canadians that
that is something very much on our minds
that is something that
we
and law enforcement and the financial
service providers have been working on
very very carefully and that's why i say
the financial the use of the financial
tools is actually going to increase in
the coming days because it was important
for us to be sure that safeguards were
in place
and i do also want to say
that
the actions we have taken
are emergency measures
due process
remains in place
charter rights
remain in place
and of course
the courts
are there
and they will be these will all be
institutions that will be there to
support canadians
okay so my follow-up is in two parts
then so you're confirming that accounts
have been frozen both personal and
corporate but you're not releasing the
information and the actual follow-up is
i'm just wondering whether the bank
accounts will be targeted of individuals
who donated to the give sengo and the
gofundme campaigns are they considered
designated people under the emergencies
act meaning that their credit cards
could be cut and financial services are
targeting them as well
okay so
the names of both individuals and
entities
as well as crypto wallets
have been shared
by the rcmp
with financial institutions
and accounts have been frozen
and more accounts will be frozen
a
crowd funding platforms and payment
service providers have started the
registration process
with
fintrac
uh in terms of the specifics on whose
accounts are being frozen
you now
have
the regulations
the financial service providers have
those regulations as well
and they working with law enforcement
will be making the operational decisions
but i do want to say really clearly to
canadians
we have now outlined with great clarity
that these blockades and occupations are
illegal
it is now time for people to go home
to take their trucks home
and to stop funding
illegal blockades and occupations
yes alex balingal with the toronto star
um just on the same subject
the warning that you're issuing to the
drivers about their accounts being
suspended and their truck insurance
being suspended is pretty unequivocal so
i'm wondering if you can say uh
or shed some light on whether the to
what degree i guess the fine the large
financial institutions are actually on
board with this and also uh clarify
exactly why you can't share
the figures why that's an operational
secret at this point
the
emergencies act
has
compelled financial service providers
to take these actions
and we have provided them
with immunity for actions undertaken in
good faith under these measures
those are two important facts
the financial service providers
have a stake in canada and the canadian
economy
and
they
are
a really important institutional pillar
of canada
they are as they are legally obliged to
do
collaborating properly and effectively
with the rcmp
with law and with law enforcement
in terms of disclosing specifics
um
all of us uh had a conversation
yesterday with law enforcement about
that
and
there was a clear view
that it's important right now
not to in any way jeopardize
the very important work law enforcement
is taking and that's why i'm not
disclosing the specifics but let me
assure you
those details
will be disclosed
in due course and soon
and and i want you to know it is
happening i do have the numbers in front
of me and
i do particularly want
people who are participating in illegal
blockades and an illegal occupation to
know
these measures
are real
they are being used
they will have an impact
and there is a really easy way
to avoid being affected by these
measures and that is
just go home
go back to work
um and i think that minister mendocino
you mentioned that um you know all the
border crossings that have been
blockaded are cleared there's been
attempts i guess to re-blockade them
um and then that's been part of the
justification you you guys have used for
the emergencies act
but you've also mentioned that you want
to
lift this emergency declaration before
the 30-day limit is up so i if you if
the concern is them returning what are
the conditions you need to see
i guess as a government as a cabinet in
order to actually lift this emergency
declaration um well
first and foremost uh one of the
conditions is that
the blockades uh are no longer
there and that is one of the reasons why
we have been going to great pains over
the last number of days to send a very
clear unequivocal message to those uh
who are
participating in them be they at a
border or in front of a legislature
including here
in ottawa in front of the parliament but
equally in in the communities and in the
neighborhoods where these are no longer
just mere disturbances of the peace
where there has been a rampant and
flagrant disregard for the law the time
is now to stop
and to go home
and you've heard me say it you've heard
mr blair say it you've heard the deputy
prime minister say it you've heard the
prime minister say it you've heard
yesterday the interim
ottawa police chief said
there should be no ambiguity right now
to anyone that is still participating in
an illegal blockade
whether it's for
some misguided under the misguided
belief that this is a lawful protest
when it is not or for some other uh more
malevolent purpose the time is to go
home
and the invocation of the emergencies
act
is a resort that we came to
as a result of the significant
challenges that law enforcement using
conventional tools had faced for the
last three weeks
and while we have made progress
while we see that the ports of entry are
open right now um i would suggest that
at this fragile moment it's precarious i
mean yesterday you just heard
mayor drew dilkins in the course of a
press conference say that there was yet
another effort to try and shut it down
again
and so yes i mean i think we all want to
be cautiously optimistic that we are
coming to the end of it um but in the
meantime as a government
we have an obligation and a
responsibility to canadians to make sure
that we are using all of the tools in
the box
and yes that includes declaring certain
areas as no-go zones that includes the
ability to commandeer the kind of assets
that are required to
preserve the flow of traffic at our at
our critical infrastructure including at
our borders um that includes choking off
proceeds currencies that may be used to
advance the illegal blockade and in the
case of the rcmp
that includes using a very um important
and time limited measure to be able to
rapidly deploy them so that we can
ensure that there is public safety so
you know
we're getting there but we're not quite
there yet and obviously it is our desire
to
see the
the measures that we have introduced
under the order sunset as quickly as
possible but that will be a decision
that is taken again very carefully on
the advice of our officials on the
advice of law enforcement and what we're
seeing and hearing on the ground
thanks we'll take one more question in
the room and then take questions from
the phone not questions
uh
on the frozen accounts
you have the operational
responsibilities to implement
but i can assure you
that
to this point there have been
accounts that have been frozen it is an
ongoing process
that will accelerate
[Music]
[Music]
that there
from extremists
institutions or democratic constitutions
and our economy
for questions over the phone please
press star one on the devices keypad
okay
being adopted
[Music]
existing methods
currently existing in canada
they are completely illegal
and completely constitutional
for us
there's a debate of the house of commons
that the house of commons participate
that it votes
on this is
completely essential
our goal
is the democratic institutions of canada
and we will proceed
absolutely
absolutely
to take
uh
it is a very delicate situation for
everybody
but the measures that are included in
the destination
all those reasons that the government
has to canadians
and
questions
thank you
so much
as a follower
my question was more when would you want
to see the house
[Music]
emergencies act it's a technical
question it's a question that the chef
uh
house leader uh delay at least
opposition we'll be discussing uh with
other
house leaders
that there are weapons
what are the plans to ensure that they
clarification i'm not saying that there
is an intelligence saying that there are
weapons
inaudible question inaudible to the
international
answer it's an important point
as i said yesterday
legislators
and there's a similarity in the rhetoric
the social media
emerging in social media and elsewhere
those are similarities that everybody
is sharing concerns about
questions
so here you're telling me that there are
no weapons in ottawa
okay
that was my follow-up question
my follow-up question was about the
children who are in downtown ottawa
some people protesters are calling for
more children to come so that children
so that the police will be impeded in
their actions
the firearms and all the risks that's
the question for the police services
there's a difference between our
different functions here
it is
create legislation to enact it
responsibility
related
we're emphasizing that they need to go
the kids need to go now
thank you very much you're done okay
unfortunately we really have to cut it
off they have to get going yeah i i
think i think we i we're joining
minister blair for the debate um but
we'll be happy to take more questions
later thank you very much
this conclusive press conference
you